Hello, this is Jim with Next Level
Commander and I am proud to announce to
you that we solved Nephilim. Now, when I
say it's big, it's big. You know me, I
never do click-baity title.
You know me, I don't usually do
Okay, fine. I don't always do
click-baity titles, but for this list,
I'm genuinely excited and you will see
why. We made a cohesive deck that
actually involves all of the Nephilim.
But, this is something magic player has
been waiting for ever since Ravnica, the
OG Ravnica, and it's been one of the
biggest what-ifs in magic's design
history. These cool, flavorful
four-colored like back then there were
no four-color commanders and these were
four-color and in the story they're
ancient gods of Ravnica and they're just
creatures. So, magic players have been
asking for some kind of fix for decades.
But, as Oscar Wilde have brilliantly
said, there are only two tragedies in
life. One is not getting what you want
and the other is getting it. How does
this guy know magic players so well?
But, because of the high expectation and
because of how difficult it is to
contain these Nephilim, they all do
different things. When the Nephilim
Epical was spoiled, people were mostly
disappointed. The general opinion was
mostly, "Yeah, we're glad it's awesome.
This is a thing, but we're probably not
going to build it cuz there's not much
to do." And I was of the same. I really
wanted this to work and I looked at it
over and over, even drafting up lists,
but it just is boring and inconsistent.
Yeah, the best way to do it is to have a
secret commander and the most
interesting Nephilim, Ink-Treader. But,
then this isn't really a Nephilim deck,
it's just a Spousing deck and there are
other commanders that scratch a similar
itch. Yeah, they're more limited in
different ways, but so is Secret
Commander. Secret Commander works well
when everything costs four mana and the
Secret Commander is easy to protect.
But, when it's four mana for a Nephilim
Epical and another four for Ink-Treader,
a single Path to Exile and there goes
your deck. So, yeah, that's where I
ended up and I quickly moved on to
bigger, wetter things. But, then 22
hours ago, my favorite subscriber,
Musket, made a comment about Nephilim.
The word streamline stood out to me.
Hold up. That's what I specialize in.
Give me any commander and my first
thought is always blink, clone,
protection, pump, undying. Can we do
that with Nephilim? And it turns out we
can. And actually, as different as they
are, the Nephilim do have subtle synergy
with each other. And as I built the
deck, the enablers began to overlap and
the Venn diagram, which I previously
thought didn't exist, emerged. Instead
of one single secret commander, what we
have is more like an assembly line where
each Nephilim brings us closer to the
end game. Glint Eye for early game
resource gathering, Doom Weaver for
deploying a winning board state, Ink
Treader is our finisher. And then there
is Witch-maw. This one is the derpy one,
but it's actually decent as a wild card
or distraction. And of course, we have
the Nephilim Epical to tie everything
together and to act as a surprise end
game boss. And what's even more
interesting is when I presented this
idea to my friend Gary, this was his
response. I was confused, but then I
realized what he was talking about. Now,
I've never seen the Naruto anime. I do
plan to eventually, but with how hyped
Gary sounded, I decided to spoil myself
to what is a very important plot line of
the show for this video. And honestly,
I'm a bit sad that I did because it's
actually so cool. It's something I
looked forward to in the life after Ugo.
So yeah, for my sacrifice, I think I
deserve a subscribe and a like. And
also, I'm going to avoid spoiling major
plot lines of the story because I don't
even I'm not even too familiar. I will
mostly talk about the characters and
their abilities, but if you don't want
to be spoiled about that either, I would
hold off on this video for now. The deck
list is in the description. Now, let's
get started. So, Pain is a group of six
villains from the Naruto series. They
share the same vision, I mean literally,
and they fight as one coordinated team.
The Deva Path is the leader tying
everything together while others handle
scouting, summoning monsters, brute
damage, energy manipulation, and even
reviving destroyed teammates. Now, I
know the comparisons are not perfect. If
you are a huge Naruto fan, you can
probably correct me, but this really
does help me visualize how the deck
works and the role of each Nephalem. And
of course, Divapath, the leader, is
Epical Nephalem. This is the commander,
the one that assembles our Nephalem
army. And also, when everything else
fails, this will turn into the final
boss that your opponents will have to
beat. Now, let's move on to phase one of
our game plan, resource gathering with
Humanpath, the Glint-Eye Nephalem. This
early stage is for gathering intel,
digging deeper into our deck for more of
the key cards, more ramp, and if you're
lucky, other Nephalem to support
Glint-Eye Nephalem. The first group of
enablers in this deck are pump spells
and protection spells. And our commander
is a really helpful source of evasion.
So, we get our hit in, sculpt our hand,
and prepare for phase two. And the first
bit of synergy overlap here is replacing
generic protection with these blink
spells. This way, when we need to, we
can reset our commander to grab the
second Nephalem, Doombrute. This one is
the Animalpath, the one that swarms the
battlefield with creatures. They're not
necessarily lethal on their own, but
they have to be dealt with. Doombrute
triggers when it hits our opponent. Now,
this brings us to another piece of cross
synergy that I've designed into the
deck. Instead of more generic pump
spells, I'm using double strike and
extra combat enablers. These cards can
enable Glint-Eye Nephalem just as well.
But, using these with Doombrute, we get
to create a massive army in just one
turn. Okay, now that we have a bunch of
these sand warriors, we go into phase
three, Blink-Search-Ink-Treader
Nephalem. Now, this one is the
Predatorpath. This is the one that can
absorb an input of energy and repurpose
and amplify. This is our finisher. How?
Well, remember those pump spells from
earlier? And ladies and gentlemen, we've
come full circle. These three Nephalems
form the core of our game plan, and 90%
of our cards are dedicated to supporting
this trio. Now, there are also some
other pretty interesting combinations.
For example, if you have these three on
the board, this is also a winning
combination, where every pump spell and
protection spell is applied to the
entire group. So, you can continue to
attack and refill your hand, and your
opponents will be dropping fairly
quickly to commander damage. So, yeah,
lots of cross energy and different
combinations we can use. But, if things
go south, we still have a few backup
plans. First one is the Yurlok Nephilim
Naraka path. This is our safety net.
When our key pieces are removed, this
will be responsible for bringing them
back for one more hit. If this piece
also falls, then that's it to our core
game plan. We have to think of something
else. And of course, there's one more,
the Witch-Maw Nephilim. Now, this one is
the Asura path. It's just a dumb beater.
It doesn't synergize with anyone. But,
this one you can deploy at any time and
just let it grow. And combine with our
commander's evasion along with our
ability to double and even quadruple
power, this can be a surprise finisher.
So, it's the kind of card that don't do
much, but your opponent also can't just
ignore it altogether. Yeah, so this one
is more like a wild card, a distraction
while you carry on with your core game
plan. But, what if the game plan falls
apart? Your squad gets annihilated. Now,
we're doing everything we can to prevent
that with all of our protection spells,
but it can definitely happen. That's
when Nephilim Epical turns into the end
boss. Yeah, in the early game, remember
when you took five damage from a
commander? Well, now it's a 16/16 with
the built-in evasion and the number of
pump spells we have, Nephilim Epical is
definitely a viable plan B. And that's
the entire deck. We do have a few pieces
dedicated to interesting and clever
shenanigans like mass cloning or Saw in
Half, but that's it. We don't have much
room for anything else. This is a very
linear deck because the Nephilims are
definitely clunky. They don't have
haste, cost four specific colored mana.
So, we do need the entire deck working
together to support them. We have 12
pieces of ramp. There should be more,
probably. If you're finding the deck
slow and inconsistent, add more ramp,
take out some pump spells or something.
These two mana dorks are a must-have.
They tap for five mana with our
commander on the field. While the higher
arks are excellent one-drops, and the
exalted is very useful in the early
game. And aside from these, I'm only
using the two-mana ramp effects to get
our commander out on turn three. And
also, because later on, we have to kind
of weave these in between the pump and
protection and all that stuff. I'm
actually tempted to try signets or
talisman, and I might make that switch
if the deck turns out to be too slow and
clunky. And for lands, now I'm not the
best at building five-color mana base,
but in this case, all fixing. We need to
make sure that we can cast a four-drop
on turn four and a four-drop plus
protection spell on turn five. So,
there's no room for utility. I'm
actually tempted to cut even Roller
Coaster Tower. We'll see. So, yeah,
that's the deck. This is my attempt to
make the best Nephilim deck you can in
2026. Sure, in the future they might
release more Nephilim. That will That
might change everything, but for now,
this is the most synergistic list I can
think of that uses all the Nephilim with
a clear game plan and path to victory
instead of like what Nuke said,
five-color slop. And also, a sweet enemy
reference, thanks to Gary. Imagine
Secret Lair or some alters with this
theme. That would be sick. That said,
this deck has its problems. Now, this is
a very laser-focused game plan with
large vulnerable pieces. People will
complain that I don't have any
interaction or removals, but I think
that should be easy for you to figure
out. If you find this deck consistent
enough, you can easily cut some pump
spells, cut some protection spells for
removals, board wipes, or even counter
spells. This is five-color. You can do
anything you want. Just make sure to
keep the core intact and gradually
explore the different options. This deck
is not the first deck you should build.
The mana base can be expensive and the
return on investment is average at best.
It is not the most powerful or the most
resilient and it can be pretty tricky to
play with all the decision trees and not
over committing. And I just came up with
this list about 10 hours ago, so I
haven't tested much. I will be testing
over the next week or two and I will
update the list. Speaking of that, we
have some giveaway business to do. First
of all, like all of our regular videos,
this video will also have two winners.
The rules are the same.
Comment, subscribe. Except this time,
one winner will be chosen randomly and
another will be based on the suggestions
you give. Because the Ugu videos, as
much as I joke, they were some of the
best experience I've had building a
deck, interacting with the community,
getting all these suggestions I have to
look through, and justifying including
or not including. And the Ugu list
changed so much from the beginning. And
I think it is now much better and much
more consistent. So, I would like to do
that. For each comment, I will take the
top suggestion as your entry and roughly
1 to 2 weeks from now, I'm going to make
a list of suggestions that made it into
the deck and pick randomly from there.
Now, the detailed rules will be down in
the descriptions, but yeah, that's
something I want to try to basically
build the deck as a community. And of
course, my card choices can be
subjective and sometimes straight up
wrong, but there's not much I can do
about that. I My goal is to build the
best deck possible and a lot of you are
maybe familiar now with my deck building
philosophy. So, yeah, if you want a
little deck building challenge, feel
free to try. If not, just comment
anything like a lot of these dads are
already doing and you still have a
chance of winning. But either way, thank
you so much for watching the video till
now and participating. And yes, we're
announcing the winners from my previous
previous giveaway. Not Homer, but the
one from the Ugu video part three. First
winner for the monster deck box is
someone who's very good at reading,
Jared Wonacott. And our second deck box
winner is Kasamori, a magic player who
doesn't want more lands. This is
blasphemy. I almost wanted to re-roll.
But yeah, congratulations to Kasamori.
And finally, the grand prize winner
winning a beautiful deck bentel. And the
winner is Camel Blake. Can't wait to see
where this Ugu arc takes us all. I guess
it takes you to the deck bentel.
Congratulations, Camel. I will do
everything I can to reach you guys. And
this is how I will be announcing future
giveaway winners as well. Thank you for
sticking around. For those of you
interested in Kappa Poppo products,
check out their site. They have some
beautiful stuff and if you're
interested, use my code levels for a 5%
discount. I will see you in my next
video.